jim fossil died of a heart attack at the
age of 71 his son john confirmed it to
the los angeles times
97 to 2003 58 53 and 1
giants contenders every year that was as
they emerged from that post parcells
punk chris right that they found their
footing with fossil after 2003 shifted
to tom coughlin and obviously won a
couple of super bowls with him but
fossil was an important bridge to what
the giants would become under coffee
agreed agreed that i mean fossil kind of
like rejuvenated the organization you're
right of that like post parcels hangover
what are they there was a few years in
flux there with the quarterback
situation and fossil like brought
attitude back to the new york giants
coaching you know he he had he was he
was a little bit of a showman he wasn't
afraid like we just saw that clip there
wasn't afraid to make bold statements
and talk to the new york media and talk
tough back to them when they talk tough
to him you know that's again that's kind
of what we like up here in new york
that's what we expect from our giants
coaches so
i have a tremendous amount of respect
for him and some of those were some of
the yeah great games i grew up you know
after my dad retired going to some of
these gym fossil games them beating your
minnesota vikings butts in that nfc
championship game was one of the coolest
games i was ever at but he has a really
special place in my heart jim fossil he
ran my
he ran my pro day before i came out in
the nfl draft he was the guy who ran my
workout for me i've known him since i
was 10 11 years old he was my dad's
quarterback look at sean payton my god
hang on a second did you see sean payton
yes oh my gosh i'm sorry to interrupt
you i was stunned to see that yeah let's
go back to watching that there he is
uh but yeah just such a special guy and
i think that you know i could speak for
the whole sims family and i don't think
anybody taught
my father me
or anything what we do as far as
quarterbacks more about mechanics and
throwing the football more than jim
fossil he was really one of the more
underrated offensive minds and
quarterback whisperers uh of the league
there for for a period of time don't
know if he quite get credit for that but
man i'm heartbroken to see that he
passed away and really my heart goes out
to their family
the world football league of 74 and 75
he was player coach for the hawaiians
and he threw the last pass in the last
game
in wfl
history
uh and
we see so many head coaches get second
opportunities and i've had people ask me
over the years you know what jim f i
mean
far lesser coaches coaches who didn't
take teams to the super bowl like hugh
jackson right
found their way back to a sideline it
really is strange to me that jim fossil
never got that opportunity i'm with you
i mean from the results we saw i mean
first off yeah tough situation with the
giants had a number of situations where
yeah the team was kind of stumbling or
you know stubbing their foot or whatever
else their toe and he got them back with
his leadership and rallying cries to me
that was like the you know the one of
the special things about jim fossil and
they played tough football
they really did and and yeah you would
think with like
you know this era we've been in for the
last 20 25 years a quarterback
quarterback we need a quarterback
whisperer a guy that has offensive ideas
fosso was that and that's where i'm i'm
with you i'm a little surprised he never
really got a second crack at it either
coach of the year in 1997 his first year
as the head coach pretty good start to
his career and then it was just a few
years later that he took the team to the
super bowl and again 58 53-1 guys with
lesser records and lesser
accomplishments ended up getting second
chances in the nfl he was a two-time ufl
champion if you remember that league it
was around for a couple of years the
football was pretty good the uniforms
were horrible beyond hideous but the
football actually you know there's
plenty of guys out there who don't make
it onto an nfl roster who can still play
football and we're seeing these other
leagues realize that now chris but uh um
yeah the ufl i enjoyed watching those
games as long as uh i found an old black
and white tv so i didn't have to really
appreciate the god awful uniforms so uh
anyway you got what else you got well i
just uh you know he's he's
like just such an awesome personality
that i was always around always made me
feel good you know always included
people in the room made everybody feel
like they're involved in the
conversation his son john i mean there's
there's a reason he's successful yeah
it's because his father raised him the
right way taught him how to work do
those things he treats people the right
way just like his father you know mike
here's a crazy story like this this is
this is crazy actually 1992 there's a
preseason game i'm in the giants locker
room after the game right i'm actually
back in the training room my dad and
hosteller are battling it out right for
the starting quarterback job it's a big
thing here in new york city sims or
hostile or hostile or sims it's all
anybody could talk about i don't know
why i'm waiting for my dad usually he
tells me go back there and wait for me
in the training room so you know it's
where the guys are taking you know you
know to tape off their ankles and
looking at their injuries after the game
or whatever and i'm kind of in a back
office there and jim fossil's there and
he comes in he's talking and blah blah
oh hey chris great to see you how you
doing blah blah he looks at me
and this is the middle
of a quarterback battle and he goes you
know he goes you know what he goes your
dad
your dad's gonna be the starting
quarterback you know that your dad's
gonna be the starting quarterback
and i was like okay okay i kind of just
brushed it off and then a few days later
and my dad has no idea a few days later
my dad starts to go you know i think
they're gonna name me the starter here
and i went you know dad jim fossil the
other night was saying this stuff to me
and he was like really like he was like
shocked but i think like jim fossil was
kind of trying to tell me so i would
tell my dad to let him know like hey
you're you're in the leader house you're
gonna be the starter but i don't know
not that maybe i'm blabbering but i just
thought that was a cool story and it's
something that i'll always remember him
by
i now must know yeah did he tell you
that before or after you filled jeff
hostetler's shoes with shaving cream it
was it was around that time frame
it was either i can't remember maybe
maybe he told you maybe he told you
because he saw you doing do it the first
time he was like
you're doing good this time
dad's gonna be the starting quarterback
you don't need to keep doing that i
can't remember if i filled his his
cleats with shaving cream in 91 or 92
but it was around that time
i just wish there had been surveillance
footage is still available yeah of of
little christopher
sitting there looking at those shoes the
gears turning in his head the devil on
the left shoulder the angel that i was
laying yeah the devil on each shoulder
and you shake that can up of barbasol
and that sound it makes that
shoes up i was laying on the ground
doing homework mike i was doing homework
and nobody was arrested explains why you
ate a hamburger off the floor of
laguardia the germaphobe laying on the
ground
good god i'm on the ground doing my
homework while my dad's back doing
whatever
and it just like the bulb went on and i
was sitting there and it's like i came
out of my textbook and i looked up and i
went wait i remember a story my dad told
me about shaving cream and guys cleats
there's hostetler's cleats let me go get
him and teach him a lesson
so that's it but jim fossil man great
career
sorry to see him go really uh enjoyed my
time with him and and really found him
to be a great person with a lot of fun
to be around uh uh just a stunner too at
71. man so uh condolences to the family
to the giants organizations to all of
his players and colleagues and anyone
who who knew and worked with jim foss
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports